[Musica]
qualcuno di voi si chiederà che cosa
c'entra lo spazio con la sostenibilità
anche perché molte persone quando si
parla di spazio iniziano a pensare a
l'enorme quantità di propellente ad
esempio che serve e che viene utilizzato
per mandare in orbita una navicella
spaziale
oppure alla quantità che oramai è
presente attorno al nostro pianeta di
immondizia spaziale o ancora degli
enormi investimenti economici che
vengono fatti in realtà
nello spazio e nella stazione spaziale
internazionale si studiano ormai da
decenni sistemi molto all'avanguardia
che sono anche attualmente applicati
applicabili per noi terrestri in quanto
a
riciclo ad esempio in quanto a
ottimizzazione delle fonti energetiche e
questo ad esempio è il sistema di
riciclo dell'acqua o meglio di tutti i
fluidi corporei presenti all'interno
della stazione spaziale internazionale
quindi se qualcuno di voi aveva
intenzione di farsi un viaggetto
sappiate che c'è una condivisione molto
profonda anche sotto questo aspetto
quindi mettetelo in preventivo ma voglio
tornare un attimo al rapporto che esiste
fra
uomo che sta svolgendo un'attività
estrema e cibo
il cibo soprattutto nessuna per
l'attività che che oggi svolgo io quindi
mi occupo anche di produzione di
determinati alimenti persone che vanno a
vivere nello spazio ma anche che fanno
altri tipi di attività come attività
speleologiche oppure attività in alta
quota ecco queste questi mondi sono
accomunati da una cosa c'è un'attenzione
spasmodica nella gestione delle derrate
alimentari cibo è una questione di vita
o di morte
io sono arrivato già ad una conclusione
ma durante questi miei quasi dieci anni
di attività a contatto con questi mondi
non sarebbe male che ognuno di noi
almeno una volta nella nostra vita
avesse l'opportunità di dipendere da una
gestione attenta del cibo cambierebbero
per che cosa ad esempio per un
astronauta il cibo diventa un vero e
proprio booster psicologico attraverso i
sensi l'astronauta ha la possibilità di
ritornare a terra per qualche istante e
di ricordare di attivare quella memoria
inconscia che grazie ai sensi gusto e
olfatto in primis ma anche tatto udito e
vista ovviamente possiamo attivare viene
chiamata memoria episodica tenetela lì
perché poi ne parleremo in maniere un
pochino più approfondita
quindi il cibo non solo da garanzia di
sopravvivenza ma dà anche è garanzia di
ad esempio poter alzare la serotonina di
avere uno stato di benessere e uno stato
spirituale di conseguenza
ottimale rispetto ad un'attività che
badate bene che si matura sei mesi
quindi non stiamo parlando di qualche
giorno di permanenza i bambini in
ambienti stressogeni ecco quello su cui
mi voglio soffermare oggi è proprio
questo rapporto fra sensi e cibo ciò che
il cibo può suscitare all'interno del
nostro corpo all'interno della nostra
mente e nei secoli
abbiamo sempre più perfezionato questo
rapporto e in definitiva se ci pensiamo
i nostri sensi hanno rappresentato fino
ad oggi
una sorta di scudo una sorta di arma di
protezione grazie ai sensi abbiamo
evitato
alimenti che in natura essendo monari
rappresentavano quasi il 99 per cento
alimenti velenosi grazie al gusto dolce
siamo riusciti a capire come
intercettare alimenti altamente calorici
quegli alimenti che ci garantivano la
sopravvivenza ecco questi due imprinting
ce li abbiamo ancora oggi a livello
primordiale ci piace tanto lo zucchero e
ci piace tanto il gusto dolce perché a
livello innato abbiamo ancora questa
eredità
quindi quando troviamo qualcosa di dolce
in inevitabilmente ci ricordiamo di
qualcosa che ci ha permesso di
sopravvivere
quindi oggi ci siamo trasformati
dicevamo
da
animali umani a scimmie che avvicinano
qui abbiamo un esemplare ad esempio e
abbiamo perso un bel po di questi valori
per strada e arrivato il momento di
recuperare e arrivato il momento
soprattutto di recuperare il nostro
rapporto intimo da cibo corpo umano cibo
e sensi bisogna iniziare a riattivare
questa nostra capacità innata bisogna
iniziare a valorizzare nuovamente il
cibo oggi purtroppo abbiamo perso
parecchie cose per strada e
innanzitutto siamo l'unico essere
vivente che può decidere di mangiare
anche quando non ha fame si può
permettere anche di non mangiare quando
ha fame ha iniziato a manipolare il cibo
ha iniziato a trasformarlo ho iniziato a
cucinarlo e ha dato vita a quella che
viene definita gastronomia c'è sempre
stato fino a 50 anni fa 70 anni fa un
progresso sempre più più elevato
questo progresso si è arenato e
purtroppo sta portando
sta tornando un po indietro quindi
stiamo siamo fermi ad un punto in cui è
necessario anche sotto l'aspetto della
sostenibilità recuperare il passo che
cosa ha a che fare tutto questo con una
sostenibilità oggi purtroppo non abbiamo
più
neanche il tempo di ray a causa delle
nostre vite
frenetiche dei nostri stili di vita di
attendere la natura di aspettare che un
frutto sia maturo non abbiamo più la
necessità di aspettare il cibo ma in
realtà oggi succede un paradosso e il
cibo che aspetta noi
e il cibo che si aspetta di essere
scelto da noi
il rischio è quello che quel cibo che
noi troviamo se noi se non lo scegliamo
non possa più essere definito il cibo
perché qualcosa che viene scartato che
viene gettato che viene purtroppo non
utilizzato non si può definire cibo
merce
quindi sostenibilità qui ho voluto
rappresentare questo termine con con un
bilanciere stiamo parlando di una di un
pezzo di ferro al quale vengono
attaccati degli elementi pesanti quindi
questi dischi questi pesi di misura
diversa di dimensioni diverse di peso
diverso
bilanciati fra di loro perché purtroppo
il tema sostenibilità
coinvolge una serie di elementi
veramente
mastodontico e quindi bisogna tenerli in
bilanciamento e per alzare questi pesi e
iniziare da quello da cui si dovrebbe
iniziare quindi le priorità bisogna
iniziare comunque ad allenarsi e capire
dove siamo ora
per farvi capire meglio questo concetto
voglio leggere questa frase di san
francesco cominciate col fare ciò che è
necessario poi ciò che è possibile e
all'improvviso vi sorprenderete a fare
l'impossibile
qui c'è sempre la scimmia di prima ve lo
garantisco so se prima che mi hanno
tagliato la testa che si allena adesso
cerco anche di sdrammatizzare questo
tema che in realtà
io sono convinto che vada che vada preso
sotto braccio non banalizzandolo ma
neanche insomma terrorizzando le persone
quindi iniziamo dal fare ciò che è
necessario fare però iniziamo io ho
iniziato ad allenarmi voglio condividere
con voi i miei step
qualcuno dirà sì va beh questo ha
scoperto l'acqua calda parto proprio
dall'acqua
io quattro anni fa ho deciso di
eliminare completamente la plastica
della mia vita qualcuno di voi lavora
già fatto ora già di fatto questa scelta
per quello prima dicevo bisogna essere
centrati su se stessi e capire dove
iniziare a lavorare subito perché non è
più il momento di riempirsi la bocca di
sostenibilità e di non fare nulla badate
bene che noi ognuno di noi è un ruolo
determinante all'interno di questo gioco
anche se un ruolo secondo voi o secondo
altri infiniti infinitesimale sono
partito dall'acqua e oggi non consumo
più ho fatto ho fatto due conti
all'interno della mia famiglia 160 kg di
plastica ho chiamato il mio servitore
del di rete idrica
mi sono fatto mandare tutti i dati
relativi alle analisi chimiche e la mia
acqua è potabile quindi non compro più
acqua in bottiglia di plastica
pianificazione un altro elemento
fondamentale devo iniziare a pianificare
devo iniziare a capire come gestire la
mia alimentazione settimanale basandomi
sulla conoscenza e rispetto delle
quantità se adesso vi chiedesse che cosa
significa una porzione di pollo e
verdura ci sarebbero ancora troppi dubbi
dobbiamo chiarire questi aspetti per
riuscire ad essere coloro che decidono
di mangiare anche quando non hanno fame
ma almeno essere consapevoli di quanto
dovrebbe essere una porzione della
comunità scientifica ci comunica quelle
che vengono definite a porzioni standard
sulla quale posti sulle quali possiamo
poggiare le nostre scelte
conoscenza e rispetto delle quantità
sistemi di cottura mettere in pratica
sistemi di cottura che salvaguardino il
cibo ma anche le mie tasche che possano
permettere di risparmiare energia
elettrica ad esempio sistemi di cottura
combinati sistema di cottura a vapore
con i cestelli alternati banale metterlo
in pratica però se non conosco non
faccio più finta di nulla
il cibo incontrato e va conosciuto
dobbiamo fermarci concentrarsi di tanto
in tanto chiudere gli occhi e allenare
anche i nostri sensi questi due elementi
sono di fondamentale importanza
sono di fondamentale importanza perché
ci permettono di recuperare
la capacità di
valorizzare la qualità del cibo in
maniera autonoma mi piace leggere anche
questa frase di una scrittrice alla
quale sono particolarmente legato
che cosa ci si aspetta dal cibo quali
cosa dovrebbe fare
secondo questa boe dovrebbe sfamare
dovrebbe far bene
l'individuo dovrebbe far bene la
comunità dovrebbe far piacere se cibo
non fa questo per tutti per tutti allora
non è cibo non è quale dovrebbe essere o
quale deve essere quindi non è quindi
cibo di qualità semplicemente non ha
cibo
vi voglio
lasciare lanciandovi una sfida
noi abbiamo quella che viene definita
non ha parlato prima memoria episodica
attraverso i sensi riusciamo ad attivare
grazie alla memoria olfattiva e
gustativa
determinate ad aprire determinati
cassetti a ricordarci determinate cose
la memoria episodica e quella che
raggruppa i nostri ricordi costitutivi
ricordi costitutivi della nostra
identità più intima e profonda
la proposta che mi faccio è questa
proviamo a costruire una memoria o delle
memorie gustative in relazione alla
sostenibilità in modo tale che quando
quindi la prossima volta vi invito a
farlo non lo possiamo fare oggi perché
purtroppo la pandemia non ci permette di
fare quello che avrei voluto però ve lo
lascio fare da soli la prossima volta
che addentare una mela provate ad
emozionarmi vi verrà in mente magari la
scimmia che cucina una scimmia che si
allena vi ritornerà in mente anche
questo contesto
e se quella mela l'avete scelta con cura
sarete soddisfatti di quello che avete
fatto per che state facendo del bene a
voi state facendo
ai vostri figli della vostra famiglia la
comunità a chi ha coltivato quella mela
al tutto
ma appena la sorsata mescolata alle
briciole del pasticcino toccò il mio
palato trasalì attento al fenomeno
straordinario che si svolgeva in
un delizioso piacere ma aveva invaso
isolato senza senza nozione di causa e
subito aveva reso indifferenti le
vicissitudini inoffensivi i rovesci
illusoria la brevità della vita non mi
sentivo più mediocre contingente e
mortale buoni sensi a tutti
[Applauso]